[Música]
sí
quien no quiere crecer a cualquier edad
quien no quiere evolucionar eso es
realmente lo importante entonces durante
los próximos minutos los voy a intentar
es algunas reflexiones y algunas
conclusiones que a las que ha llegado de
cómo eso puede ocurrir no tendría que
ocurrir mira para empezar y ver la
realidad en la que estamos un par de
datos que me parecen muy impactantes
el primero cada año le ganamos tres
meses a la muerte
fijaros de lo que estamos hablando
fijaros el gráfico desde el inicio del
siglo pasado a donde estamos ahora al
2016 1718 la mujer cuando nacía tenía
una esperanza de vida de 35 años hoy
tiene de 85 años los hombres han pasado
de 40 a 80 años realmente esto es una
revolución realmente la longevidad es un
gran desafío que tenemos que tenemos que
abordar es muy importante y se tiene que
ver lo tenemos que ver desde tres
vértices diría yo el primero el social
porque van a estar mucho tiempo
conviviendo varias generaciones la
convivencia es a generaciones es muy
importante el segundo es el laboral edad
de jubilación
conocimiento experiencias cómo se
aprovecha toda esa experiencia y el
tercero el económico daros cuenta son
muchas más personas que van a estar
durante muchísimo más tiempo consumiendo
entonces es tremendamente importante
posiblemente la esperanza de vida esa
prolongación de la esperanza de vida
está siendo uno de los grandes retos
socioeconómicos de la historia de la
historia de la humanidad
edad cronológica edad biológica estamos
un poquito obsesionados con el
calendario estamos mirando el calendario
ante la crisis la crisis de los 40 se
crisis en los 50 la crisis de los 60
vamos de crisis en crisis pero realmente
lo importante es la edad biológica la
edad biológica en la edad cómo se van
consumiendo nuestras nuestras células
y esa edad se puede hacer mucho para
para prolongarla parece que ese
deterioro que se produce en las células
es como consecuencia de cuatro factores
el genético
la alimentación el ejercicio físico y el
estrés
sobre tres de ellos podemos actuar
directamente fijaros también que la edad
cronológica puede ser como un concierto
lastre muchas veces es un lastre porque
te enfrentas a esa edad tecnológica a
esa edad cronológica y pareceres a esa
edad cronológica es la que es
pensar en la jubilación a los 65 años
cuando se decidió que la jubilación era
a los 65 años hoy esos 65 años
posiblemente sean los 45 y seguimos con
la misma con la misma ley tenemos que
dar una vuelta tanto social como
económica a muchas leyes que vienen de
una época de una época anterior que no
es realmente lo que está ocurriendo hoy
porque estamos en una realidad
completamente distinto
sabéis lo que es la generación silver
el silver que ya sabe lo que la
generación silver
bueno pues yo soy un militante activo de
la generación silver aquí tenéis a un
militante activo además de la generación
silver somos personas de más de 55 o 60
años no terminamos de poner de acuerdo
nos estamos en cada vez vamos bajando lo
un poco ya estamos en los 55 y que están
plenamente activos que quieren seguir
disfrutando de la vida que quieren
seguir aprendiendo que queremos seguir
compartiendo y que somos una gran
revolución porque daros cuenta que
millones de personas millones de
personas van a seguir ahorrando van a
seguir viajando van a seguir
emprendiendo personas de unas
generaciones que hacen muy poco eran
ancianos ese es una absoluta revolución
que están cambiando está cambiando la
teoría del ciclo de vida las teorías
tradicionales del ciclo de vida se están
cambiando antes el ciclo de vida tenía
como 3 la niñez de la educación
trabajaba siete jubiladas que es lo que
está ocurriendo ahora que está
apareciendo un nueva una nueva
generación que aparece entre los 55 y
los 60 hasta los 75 y seguirá aumentando
que estás plenamente activo y que
quieres hacer un montón de cosas cuál es
el riesgo de esta de esta generación
silver porque tiene un riesgo bueno lo
primero ser mayores ya no lo que era
estamos de acuerdo no entonces ser
mayores ya empieza a ser otra empieza a
ser otra cosa pero esta generación tiene
un riesgo y el riesgo es que sigue
haciendo lo mismo que hacían las
generaciones anteriores y ese es el gran
riesgo que tiene que sigan con esa
rutina y si siguen con esa rutina no van
a aprovechar todas las posibilidades que
les dan esta nueva esta nueva etapa
no aprovechar esas esas oportunidades
realmente es un riesgo es un problema y
tenemos que ver cómo somos capaces de
que no ocurra y para que no ocurra
podemos hacer una cosa
seguir creciendo entonces si seguimos
creciendo si seguimos quería tener las
ideas claras si queremos aprender si
queremos innovar si queremos emprender
esa será la solución para que no nos
ocurra el quedarnos estancados y
quedarnos con eso con esa edad que
pueden pasar días y sigues porque porque
no ha sido capaz de ver la oportunidad
de hacer cosas distintas de aprovechar
esa gran oportunidad que tienes de 15 15
20 años y se me ha ocurrido
reflexionando sobre esto
y decir oye pues porque no coges y haces
una reflexión para que tienes un poco
más de tiempo de cómo se puede crecer a
esta edad sea que habría que hacer tú
que estás en la edad que tendrías que
hacer para hacerlo todo se me ocurrió
hacer esta reflexión y lo primero cuando
hago esta reflexión y empiezo a decir
bueno pues pues deberíamos de hacer que
os lo voy a contar tenemos que hacer
esto el otro lo primero que hice fue
internet como hago prácticamente siempre
para tener más más información no para
documentar mejor todo él hice esta
pregunta a internet no cómo se puede
crecer a cualquier edad pero esta vez la
respuesta no me gustó
esta no me valía para lo que quería
hacer ni me va ni me iba a dar la
oportunidad de seguir de seguir
creciendo no te dije oye pues no tienes
que ser neuronas y ponerte a pensar en
qué es lo que tienes que hacer cuando te
pones a pensar lo que tienes que hacerlo
concretando en siete en siete claves en
siete aspectos que me parecen muy
importantes el primero el propósito sin
un propósito es imposible crecer como
decía séneca ningún viento es favorable
para el barco que no sabe cuál es su
puerto de destino
tenemos que tener ese propósito ese
propósito que nos guía ese propósito que
cuando vienen las dificultades sabes
cómo superarlo eso es lo verdaderamente
importante tener ese propósito el
segundo es la actitud la actitud
positiva porque se puede crecer sin
tener una actitud positiva sin ver la
botella medio llena tener esa actitud
positiva es ser valiente salir de la de
la zona de confort mirar nuevos
horizontes que quieras hacer eso es ser
eso es tener una actitud positiva es ver
las soluciones y no los problemas es el
generoso es compartir está en la actitud
de que estás en una empresa trabajando
las 10 de la mañana y te llamas recursos
humanos y te dicen sube pues siempre
tienes que subir no sé por qué sube
entonces pues siempre están más altos
entonces tú ves y dices oye
se prejubilan
un problema o una oportunidad tú decides
eso es realmente lo que tienes que tener
lo que tienes y lo que tienes que
valorar porque como muchas veces decimos
la actitud lo es todo entonces esa
actitud de querer hacer las cosas esa
actitud de ir hacia adelante y de
eliminar barreras la tercera
es la energía porque para crecer no
puedes estar agotado si estás agotado es
imposible que grecia entonces es muy
importante tener la energía fue en un
curso y me di cuenta de esto fue un
curso de hace 78 años que hablaba de
esto la verdad mis expectativas cultiva
el curso no eran muy grande de bueno un
curso de energía que será esto pero fui
y realmente me sirvió de mucho porque
saque como dos o tres ideas que es lo
importante que muchas veces nos damos
cuenta de mantener la energía durante
todo el día pero muchas veces tiene
estos bajones y parece que se puede
mantener y fundamentalmente es muy
sencillo lo único que hay que hacerlo
implica dos cosas una física y otra
mental la física es la alimentación
bueno
a otro litro de agua las cinco comidas
el control del alcohol de los dulces de
las grasas descansar y hacer ejercicio
físico y otra mental por ejemplo en mi
caso pues hago mindfulness y me viene
muy bien entonces está muy bien entonces
me vais a decir bueno lo de siempre no
mente sana in corpore sano' y es verdad
pero la diferencia es que hay que
hacerlo entonces si tú te coges una
rutina esa rutina de hacer una
determinadas cosas tienes y puedes tener
esa energía que te permite hacer muchas
cosas y tener esa vitalidad de poder
hacer seguir haciendo cosas porque es
muy difícil crecer si no tienes la
vitalidad para poder para poder hacerlo
el cuarto que posiblemente es uno de los
que más me gusta es la mente del
principiante o sea al desarrollar la
mente de principiante porque en la mente
del principiante
tiene muchas posibilidades porque puede
hacer muchas cosas en la del experto y
que acaba en muy poca porque lo sabe
todo entonces esa mente del principiante
es fundamental para para crecer a
determinadas edades como los como los
silver parece que lo sabemos lo podemos
saber todo pero la diferencia entre
querer seguir aprendiendo o querer que
lo sabes todo es totalmente diferencial
es brutal la diferencia porque en un
sitio seguirás evolucionando y en el
otro cada vez te vas haciendo más
pequeño te vas empequeñeciendo porque te
estás quedando estancado entonces esa
mentalidad de querer mirar hacia hacia
adelante y querer tener esa casi casi
segunda juventud y de la creatividad de
cuando eras niño es volver a eso es
volver a tener permanentemente esas
ganas de querer de querer seguir
evolucionando la quinta
en la red de contactos
que es tremendamente importante y sobre
todo a determinadas edades os lo digo
por experiencia tener una buena red de
contactos tener unas buenas relaciones
cuidarla ahora mismo hay muchas
herramientas que te permiten hacerlo
pero lo que tienes que tener en cuenta y
lola verdaderamente es es vital es
gestionarla y tener los fundamentos de
la calidad de esos contactos eso es lo
verdaderamente importante cuando tienes
contactos las cosas son como mucho más
sencillas te salen como mucho más
natural siempre puedes pedir apoyo
además darnos cuenta que estamos
entrando lo silben una edad donde la
soledad puede ser un problema y puede
ser un riesgo pero si tienes relaciones
y tienes contactos
eso se mitiga muchísimo entonces red de
contactos es un tema fundamental lasexta
posiblemente venga un poco por de
formación profesional es la adopción de
las nuevas tecnologías las nuevas
tecnologías son una aliada tenemos que
entender las tecnologías y aplicarlas en
la medida que las necesitemos no no es
esto no va conmigo no hay que
entenderlas y aplicarlas porque nos
ayudan muchísimo nos ayuda en la gestión
del tiempo nos ayudan a podernos
comunicar nos ayudan a poder evolucionar
yo conozco personas de 80 años
que han pedido una tablet para su
cumpleaños y conozco directivos que se
han jubilado han dicho maestra de la
tecnología nueva conmigo y han
desaparecido esto es una realidad y es
así entonces adoptarlo es entender es
tener esa mente abierta de principiante
que quieres hacer cosas y que cada vez
vas avanzando y vas progresando y la
séptima es el amor
porque se puede quiere hacer sin amor
evidentemente yo por ejemplo y no
estaría aquí sin el amor y el apoyo de
mi familia pero impensable que pudiera
estar aquí es así si si lo pensamos por
un instante posiblemente en las épocas
de nuestra vida en las que más hemos
crecido en las que más rápido nos hemos
desarrollado han sido las las épocas en
la que mayor amor mayor amor había en
nuestro alrededor que fundamental
entonces como veis son siete claves
siete aspectos que mezclan
temas emocionales y temas racionales
porque realmente nosotros para crecer
igual que les pasa a las plantas lo que
necesitamos es tanto nutrientes y agua
como cariño y cuidados son las dos cosas
y es tremendamente importante que eso lo
hagamos así se me ha ocurrido que
tenemos fuentes para para inspirarnos en
lo que es ser silver east y estar en
esta en esta edad he puesto unos cuantos
hay muchos más podían llenar esta sala
pero voy a referirme a tres de ellos que
me parecen que no son tan conocidos que
me parecen que son muy relevantes
la primera es
la abuela moses es una pintora
norteamericana que expuso por primera
vez en el museo de arte moderno de nueva
york a los 77 años y estuvo pintando
hasta los 101 no volamos es
el segundo es john
perdón
inventor de la cocacola a los 55 y el
último es jon klein
un astronauta estadounidense que fue el
primer astronauta estadounidense que
salió al y dio una vuelta por el espacio
pero es que y eso lo hizo en 1962 pero a
los 77 años fue también la persona de
mayor edad que ha vuelto a salir al es
al espacio un y por ahí pongo también
como no puede ser otra forma como si un
rockero a mayaguez que también está en
esa edad es la silver que siempre va a
ser va a ser silver no iba a ser un
chaval
bueno pues
como el movimiento se demuestra andando
hace un año y medio el tiempo pasa pasa
volando estaba en los umbrales de los 61
como decir como como se han comentado
antes estaba el director general en una
gran institución llevaba la tecnología
me lleva muy bien con mi jefe y con mis
compañeros tenía un sueldo razonable
bueno
el sitio para estar hasta los 65 años y
jubilar de allí pero decidí que no que
esto de la nueva generación que daba
muchas buenas oportunidades y además me
di cuenta de una cosa muy importante que
era esta que además lo publicase me hice
una camiseta y lo publiqué en las redes
sociales que era demasiado joven para
jubilarme pero ya también demasiado
demasiado viejo para tener jefe pues
llevaba toda la vida con el jefe y ya
estaba bien de tener si quería ser mi
propio jefe entonces a partir de ahí lo
que fui es hacer cosas distintas y en
estas hacer cosas distintas en este año
y medio he visto que se han cubierto con
muchísimas muchísimas esas expectativas
que tenía se han superado y se han
superado porque te das cuenta que
siempre siempre tienes la edad para
crecer siempre tiene la edad para
compartir siempre tiene la edad para
seguir enseñando y para que te sigan
enseñando no entonces doy clases en dos
escuelas de negocio durante ese año
puedo haber dado más de 50 conferencias
en universidades en coloquios pequeños
asesor a ongs fundaciones asesor a
empresas compartes aprende un montón de
lo que te dicen os aseguro que
sé muchísimo más que se había hace un
año y medio muchísimo más que sabía hace
un año sin ninguna sin ninguna duda
incluso me atrevía a escribir un libro
que es digitalizado desaparece que está
en su quinta edición y que los y los
beneficios van a una ong de
emprendimiento social
hay que seguir evolucionando yo creo que
es mirar uno de los temas más bonitos de
este último año ha sido hacer en
diciembre en el país retina delante de
1.800 jóvenes hablándoles del empleo del
futuro en una en una
en un evento es el país con futuro no se
te pueden olvidar
hechos de esos y eso lo puedes hacer
porque estás en una en una dinámica
distinta
y termino
todos vamos a ser silver todos entonces
yo os animo a seguir compartiendo y a
seguir que ir creciendo seguir creciendo
evolucionar como decía el peter drucker
la mejor forma de predecir el futuro es
crearlo
esa es la mejor forma un futuro un
futuro en el que no seremos viejos
por más tiempo sino jóvenes por más años
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]